en la Meca kabul gaza y Jerusalén miles
de fieles se reúnen Para rezar este
viernes termina el mes del ramadán
dedicado a la juventud y a la oración
para los musulmanes es el momento de
celebrar el eight alfiter una de las
mayores fiestas del islam su fecha se
elige según el calendario del lunes el
late comienza el primer día del décimo
mes Cuando llega la Luna nueva tras la
limosna llega el momento de la oración
colectiva más larga de lo habitual el
resto del día se dedica a acciones
piadosas intercambios de deseos y
regalos pero este año la inflación se
coló a la fiesta y la canasta de compras
de ley tuvo que reducirse como aquí en
Pakistán
el público lucha contra la inflación y
tiene que tomar decisiones difíciles
entre la comida y la ropa La mayoría de
la gente sólo va a comprar para sus
hijos los padres no compran para sí
mismos
significa paz y compartir más allá de su
dimensión religiosa es una oportunidad
para que millones de musulmanes
compartan una fiesta con la familia y
los amigos